all right everybody i don't really want
to waste too much time with like a
slow build up to the content today
because there's just so much to get to
before donald trump humiliates himself
at the whirlpool factory in ohio
scheduled for 15 minutes from now
could be hours from now we just don't
know
i just have so much stuff to show you
now you might be wondering how do i know
trump's going to humiliate himself today
well it's just that type of day
uh he's already humiliated himself twice
today let's go through donald trump's
day starting leaving the white house on
the way to ohio
whoa donald trump asked about his claim
that children are almost
immune to coronavirus oh let me turn
down my earpiece it's a little loud
um here is what donald trump had to say
all you have to do is read the
newspapers or meet the read the medical
reports
read the medical reports and then that's
where you're going to see
here donald trump seems to act as if the
nra is a person
i think the nra should move to texas
and lead a very good and beautiful life
the nra
needs to lead a nice and beautiful life
then donald trump uh landed
in uh where did he la he landed in ohio
and he spoke to a very small crowd and
here's
one thing he had to say take a listen to
this
nobody ever would ever think even
possible
because he's following the radical left
agenda take away your guns
destroy your second amendment take away
you
guns no religion no anything
is that sounds almost like john john
lennon's song imagine
hurt the bible hurt god he's against god
he's against guns
he's against energy our kind of energy
biden doesn't want energy he just he
wants
low energy world um so it's already
embarrassing right embarrassing himself
on the way to ohio embarrassed himself
upon landing in cleveland
ohio and then now we're standing by uh
donald trump to
deliver remarks at a whirlpool factory
yeah not only um biden hates energy
he hates matter he hates gravity and in
fact
all of these fights that we're seeing
people coming out against energy
i want to actually shift the focus where
are the anti-gravity
advocates that's the for me that's the
new battle
lines that we should expect to be
fighting very very soon so
a humiliating day for donald trump
already and we're expecting more of it
momentarily so i'm i'm really glad
you're joining me to be perfectly frank
um okay other updates um
two super chats andrew sprague says any
guesses how many words he'll
mispronounce this time
i have a video i'm going to play for you
related to that momentarily and it
relates very powerfully to plasma
uh carmen edwards says hey david do bots
donate money yeah
carmen not only are you fake because
you're a fake subscriber to my channel
even your super chat contribution is
fake you donated a fake five dollars
it's completely fake and phony
we are in the middle of a level three
hype train on twitch
i want to say thanks to benutsername
bit the freak
nikki quincy i'm
inconsolable has subscribed for 11
months at tier 3
with the message your stream titles keep
getting more and more
amusing thanks as always by the way
twitch
you is way more fun than
youtube you oh my god i don't i don't
know what i'm having trouble parsing the
language but i love it
i'm inconsolable of course the big donor
formerly formerly known as turkey bacon
and cheese
um and a lot is happening so we're
pushing for
for level five there um
seth barham says please remind
progressives that want to stay home
in november that victories like corey
bush's are meaningless without someone
to sign the bills
at the top very well said very very well
said
so there's an amazing video i'm gonna
play for you
i posted this to my um uh
twitter earlier okay this is a new video
from the daily show
and i posted it with the message i'm
thrilled to see the heavy inclusion of
plasma
here although i prefer the spelling
plasma p l o z m u h
i don't i'm not like a big daily show
fan since jon stewart left i don't think
i've ever actually watched an episode on
tv
this is really really good okay let's
watch this together
he's having trouble reading laura when
they gaze upon
your semites yosemites towering
sequoias there's something off there and
how many gaps can you make
every single day this is the very
definition
of totalitarianism he increasingly
sounds like
one of those bad lip reading videos you
see on the internet they delivered a
swift and swiping you know that sweeping
it was swift and it was sweeping we find
that he has trouble getting through the
words
france japan sweden finland illustrious
s grant in minneapolis thank the
minneapolis police
just like we did in minneapolis plasma
plasma plasma
the plasma plasma we need plasma the
poor man he can't read a problem there's
nothing better than plasma this is this
is the best moment of this thing it's
just like we did in
minneapolis plasmid plasma the plasma
plasma we need plasma the poor man he
can't read a prompter either the same
spirit that drove america's founders
jesus doesn't even know what year it is
the choice in 220
for all new homes offices and buildings
by 2 30
in april of 2014 as
this is so well done 2014
minneapolis difficulty keeping his train
of thought
blazing fast broad walk and and if you
think i am announcing that my
administration is
and we've he's on an obstacle course
that makes it look like he is just not
up to this job
so well done so so so well done
absolutely fantastic and real
the plasma moment for me is the moment
of this thing we did in
minneapolis plasma clasp plasma the
plasma plasma we need plasma the poor
man he can't
oh man it's just it's just so good so
that
that's really special and i tweeted that
out earlier and you can you can retweet
me or skip me just retweet the video
from the daily show i don't care
i'm not looking for uh i'm not looking
for
for uh the the credit there um
oh boy it looks like we failed on
today's hype train that's bad we had
three four days in a row of a successful
consecutive level five hype train it
looks like we failed that's sad
twitch let us down today
yeah massive amounts of plasma not
seeming to help
in any way over on youtube
the super chats are pouring in like a
faucet zest the african says from the
standpoint of water how ridiculous is it
that trump's children and donors occupy
so much of his staff how is that even
legal
yeah i mean that's that's an ongoing
issue
inconsolable says it's not that
confusing i just mean that your twitch
persona is way more fun than your
youtube
professional persona oh my god
um kmb says real five bucks from a real
member
yeah a lot of people have taken a
personal issue with
sam cedar firing a shot across the bow
and
uh suggesting that some of our now 900
and hold on 922 000 youtube subscribers
sam cedar said he smells bots he smells
bots and i found it offensive
from the standpoint of you guys because
you are all real people real people
sending messages subscribing all of that
stuff so i i
didn't like to see that from sam cedar
but the latest
in terms of the projections are we are
now projected to reach 1 million
subscribers according to socialblade
on december 11th you not me
not bots you have moved up the projected
date
for hitting one million
youtube subscribers from january 9th
okay
last monday when we hit 900k
we were projected to get to a million on
jan 9
j or jan as they say in some european
countries
yan ix you have subscribed
at such a clip that we have moved it up
almost an entire month
to december 11th and we are down to just
we need to move it up
five more weeks five weeks and a day to
get to november third which is my goal
my goal is
one million by november third
the dream would be as donald trump's
loss in the presidential race is
announced
we breach one million
youtube subscribers so that's where we
are right now
and i'll keep you posted about that um
there is a discussion of doing
suns out guns out if i whoever loses i
guess has to do sun's out guns out
between me and sam cedar i'm open to
that i don't own
as i said what's traditionally known as
a male
tank top some people use the very off
color phrase a wife beater but i don't
like that phrase some people call it an
a shirt
but i would be i would consider that i
would consider that
um okay let's see what else we've got
here
alexa says man you're missing great
outros from trevor noah the last couple
minutes skits are
golden tom denny says keep killing it
david with a 50
super chat some people asking what's the
biggest super chat i've ever
gotten i think it maxes at 500 i don't
think it goes any bigger than that
and interestingly the two biggest super
chats the 500s
have come from a norwegian viewer and a
swedish viewer
social democracy very powerfully
supporting independent media it was
norway and sweden i believe that made
those uh the big super chats diane
marzoni says here's something pretty
darn funny trump arguing with himself
yeah i saw we can look at that i did see
that it is pretty well done let's take a
quick look at it
um here it is oh we've got an ad
but we are going to have that
momentarily
look at some of these charts in numerous
categories
uh we're lower than the world let me
explain
right here take a look
you can test too much you do know that
what it says is when you have somebody
that
has where there's a case we're last
no but you're not reporting it correctly
we have cases our testing i believe this
is the testing yeah check it out new
cases new cases new cases
the top one that's a good thing not a
bad thing we test more we have
now take a look death is way down from
where it was take a look at this
these are the tests doing it leveled out
this excuse me
where it was is much higher than where
it is right now but you don't know that
that's my report as of yesterday
wait a minute you have to go by where
look here is the united states you have
to go buy the cases what's called
science we have more cases don't we get
credit for that
[Music]
well we show more cases they are dying
that's true
and you ha it is what it is now it's
going down again
uh and you know there are those that say
the world is so very just
read the manuals read the book this one
didn't reach my desk
yeah so that's that's pretty well done i
think that that is uh that's that's
pretty good
um where did i find that diane just sent
it to me
ethan montierth says flat earther is
already at war with gravity maybe trump
f e flat earth conspiracy do dubitat
ibrius says if a woodchuck could
chuck wood do you think it would toss a
log at trump
that's a fair question it's a
philosophical question more than an
empirical one
sam says i am baby okay
uh zodiac says my name is david pakman
watch me and my 12 inch zucchini go to
work on pog
champs oh god um there was actually a
big announcement made today
on uh twitter um which i retweeted i
think it was
gm hikaru who made the announcement let
me see here yeah here it is
whoops oh my god hold on hyped to
announce the fullchest.com pogchamps two
lineup of players
including oh god this is risky xqc
forsen dog dog icha fu
austin on twitter i know real ms kiff
thor bjornsson easy with aces
call me carson tf blade
iw dominate lol scissors
waga gaming or wagga grip xj
qt cinderella and last
certainly not least i hope deepakman
um so very very exciting
[Music]
can you guys feel the hype or what where
am i in this compilation
there i am wow wait what did it say
under my name
oh politics okay that's fair i have no
obvious problem with this promo let me
put it that way
so that's really exciting and the
trainings uh the trainings continue
there so i appreciate that
um what else thank you to rainbow
tangoy who is new member number one
today at joinpackman.com i appreciate
that
um also thanks to crispyboy gaming for
the subscription
over on twitch prime shaners
says check out the arizona lawsuit for
mountainside fitness sued to open up and
completely misunderstood the ruling
okay i'll look into that stefan l says
greetings from denmark on a scale of one
to ten how many chromosomes do you
reckon
donald trump is missing you know that
that's not my area of expertise so i
wouldn't be able to comment
ml says so sam cedar smelled bots
whoever smelled it dealt it i would say
that's actually not a bad retort that's
not a better tort
forever dunkley says even though your
subs are not bots
some of them are realistically dead i
also have commitment issues so i'm
afraid to subscribe here's five dollars
as a sorry oh my god
um it's much cheaper to just subscribe
than to send me five dollars um
but yeah we are at we're at 922 000
subscribers right now that's a fantastic
number that's a
absolutely incredible number what else
did i have here
um i had okay trump's tweet oh tru
yeah trump tweeted a trump tweeted an
obama gate video yesterday
i'll show this to you guys it's we owe
the world an
apology and an explanation the president
of the united states
tweeted this yesterday trump will not be
present highly critical
biased text messages between senior fbi
officials peter strzok and lisa payne
there will be no
question about the outcome of this
election
and she got ahead of herself this
utterly stunned this campaign
uh head home you should get some sleep
we'll have more to say tomorrow
our constitutional democracy enshrines
the peaceful transfer of power the
peaceful transition of power
is one of the hallmarks of our democracy
i want to do everything we can to help
you succeed because if you succeed
then the country succeeds these
declassified documents that were just
released
okay anyway i don't even want to play
the whole thing but the point is trump
is tweeting
conspiracy videos about barack obama so
we have that
and then what else did i have oh okay i
already played these so actually we're
we're doing okay
the only other thing i wanted to do was
just review that we have now surpassed
five million coronavirus cases in the
united states yesterday
i told you we were close we have now
indeed surpassed it and
tragically more than 162 000 deaths it's
only 3 16 p.m
on the east coast here but we already
have 34 000 confirmed cases and this is
bearing in mind that florida hasn't been
testing because of hurricane isaiah's
and california has been understating
cases as well
yesterday we had once again 55
000 new cases probably an understatement
and
1 300 1319 deaths and
even states like massachusetts which
have been doing very well
as you can see starting to pick back up
and if you look at a seven day moving
average
it's it's happening everywhere it's
happening everywhere
more so in red states but we're all in
the same pool if you pee in the deep end
deep end it's gonna hit us um
do i have any memes today i do i do have
some memes today
um where do i have them where did i put
those memes oh here we go okay
so someone has been really having a good
time with my uh
big big ideas statements and they put
this together
i don't know if this is a direct quote
but i think it's close i'm churning
ideas here i'm french pressing ideas i'm
extracting ideas very powerfully like an
espresso machine
i'm sauteing ideas and all of these
other things
i'm hydraulically pressing ideas
dremeling
ideas and all of this stuff all the time
so that's a good one
um and then here's another one that was
sent to me which is weird i don't even
get this one
summer fun with the boys 2020
i don't know who this is hold on can i
zoom this
i don't know who who is this does
anybody know who that is that's me
this is donald this is sam cedar that's
ted cruz but i don't actually know who
this is on the left here
let's see if anybody in the chat knows
who that is
nobody knows okay ammon bundy that's who
i don't know if that's who that is
oh people say a bunch of people saying
it's ammon bundy maybe it is all right
huh okay anyway um look at how look at
how even my skin tone is compared to
donald trump's here
see how that look at that it's like he's
wearing
a mask almost and my skin is completely
even here which i think is just really
great
anyway you can send me your memes
to david davidpakman.com
or post them to the david pakman show
subreddit
and i can pull them off of there if
people prefer
and that's of course completely up to
you i want to say
thank you to uh oh
maybe sam cedar is right a viewer named
vubot mexico mix subscriber bot
has just signed up and is new member
number two
i think their real name is maybe andrew
but still
vubot mix subscriber bot that's not
going to help me in this battle against
sam cedar
also thanks to william applewhite who is
new member number
three today at joinpakman.com
cindersole has subscribed with prime on
twitch and says david thank you for your
overview
your sharing almost makes these
briefings bearable all right thank you
um wildest superior and golock
are also supporting on twitch newly
which is very much appreciated
hugo escalante has grabbed a youtube
membership
crypto monkey says luckily having
universal healthcare here here in
australia means easy access to all the
plasma that we need i'm i have plasma
envy
ought to be perfectly frank gregory seco
says missouri is breaking all types of
50-year streaks
blues win the cup chiefs win the super
bowl and now a clay
will not hold the missouri first
congressional district
and we expand medicaid beautiful
essential says even if you don't watch
the main daily show you should check out
trevor noah's between the scenes he has
good commentary
that's ghastly says what do you think of
democratic socialism i probably have 50
videos about that on my youtube channel
so i'm not going to delve into that too
much right now
uh i am a social democrat to be clear
not a democratic socialist though
zip zap zip zap zip has subscribed with
twitch prime
um d-man says i have an online bet
trumpf will not last the full term in
office do you mean this term or if he
gets a second term
as you know presidential term ends on
january 20th
stake six dollars and 38 cents odds 11-2
potential payout 41.47 oh i see oh okay
okay you literally have a bet i see
sam says i'm baby again sean king says
hey david for thanksgiving i will stuff
my tofurky with
plasma will you donate that seems like a
worthy cause
peter says 922 000 is a beautiful number
the most beautiful number we've ever
seen the numbers are only going up
well you know what's crazy we are at 922
000 subscribers on youtube but if only
200 more people sign up and we've got 8
200 people watching right now we're only
200 away
from 923 000 so we may be
we may soon abandon 922
000. a user named ireland
multiple sclerosis and me has subscribed
on youtube
alexander verdant says after all this
election craziness is over it would be
cool if you hosted a one-time
minecraft stream i have no idea how to
play minecraft it would just be me
clicking around alex kepcke says i told
my fiance
i want to have a kid she asked me why
i told her so david pakman
can have another subscriber that's the
hero we need right now
clip it wow that's so generous
i can't believe that aaron coolidge
beard
says trump was so hoping the beirut
explosion was a terrorist attack to try
and boost his
poles everyone saw right through it i
have a about a 10-minute clip i recorded
on about that today
uh trump axios has interview but it's
actually an episode of
curb oh this has got to be funny i want
to take a look at that
see what people have here whoa okay
let's get off of that that was not the
right thing to click
whoa whoa whoa whoa um
oh i see what's going on
okay i think i've got the right url here
is this uh yeah here okay good
now we've got it
here we go yeah i have not seen this but
i'm guessing it's
very funny
oh it's good already oh my god
thank you so much
[Music]
if you look at death yeah it's going up
again that's daily death take a look at
some of these charts i'd love to we're
going to look let's look and if you look
at death
yeah it started to go up again
well right here the united states is
lowest
in numerous categories
uh we're lower than the world lower than
the lower than
europe and what in what take a look
right here here's death
oh you're doing death as a proportion of
cases i'm talking about death as a
proportion of population
that's where the u.s is really bad much
worse than south korea germany etcetera
you can't you can't do that you have
white country you have to go by
you have to go by where look here is the
united states
you have to go by the cases the cases
why not as a proportional population
what it says is when you have somebody
that has
where there's a case oh okay the people
that live from those cases
it's surely a relevant statistic to say
if the us
has x population and x percentage of the
best episode of curb ever
death of that population
we'll look at south korea for example 51
million population 300 deaths
it's like it's crazy i do it's people
you think they're faking their
statistics south korea an advanced
country
because they have a very good
relationship with the country but you
don't know that
and they have spikes look here germany
low 9 000.
here's one right here united states
you're taking the number of cases okay
look
we're last meaning we're first lost i
don't know what we're faced with
is it again it's cases
and we have cases i mean so fantastic
thousand americans died i understand i
understand all cases
it's different no but you're not
reporting it correctly jonathan
i think i am but if you take a look at
this other chart
look this is our testing i believe this
is the testing
app yeah we do more tests now wait a
minute well don't we get credit for that
that's nice that's really well done
starting over i like that that's very
solid i think that one's really really
good
um okay
all right let's see what else we've got
going on here i think we have to settle
down as we get closer oh matthew miller
has grabbed a subscription at
joinedpakman.com
so has sean tuhey who is new member
number
five today laurie rowlandson
is new member number six alissa reuter
hello reuters is new member number seven
desean
muldrow is new member number eight
and um hold on i'm missing one person
here
thomas welch there it is thomas welch is
new member number
nine today at joinedpakman.com i
appreciate that also thanks to m bronov
for the twitch prime subscription um as
we are
waiting now 15 minutes late already for
donald trump
to deliver humiliating remarks at the
whirlpool
factory in ohio uh people pointing out
that bitcoin is doing well what do i
own bitcoin at i don't know but i'm i'm
way up
i mean at this point it's very very very
far up
and i mentioned that i picked up some
bitcoin in mid-march
when the pandemic was getting going and
i i've bitcoin from 2017
and then i picked some up in mid-march
and then it went cuckoo
and maybe i should sell i don't know i
mean i'm not
like you know particularly bullish on
the long-term prospects for sure
but um that is something that is going
on maybe i'll say a little more about
that at some other point
milo k says i declare 925
000 subscribers by the end of the stream
is the goal
oh it looks like we're about to go live
we are at 900
and we're still at 9 22. i mean i
i would love it if we got to 925 000 by
the end of the stream but that's a very
very ambitious goal
well what's going on here a large
residential washer
all right so they're talking about
washing machines right now so we're
going to wait
clearly no no trump yet so we're gonna
wait and stand by for that
let me take just a brief moment to
mention if you're looking to do me
a favor that costs you nothing just
following us
on our social platforms or twitch or
youtube is very much appreciated
if you are in the camp of folks
that likes what i do and has a dollar
eighty a month or two bucks a month to
support our work
we're mostly funded by people who get
memberships on my website
so um i would invite you to feel welcome
to but certainly not obligated to grab a
membership at joinpakman.com it's really
cheap we have a coupon code here that
works
perfectly 2020 now it'll chop 66
off of the price of a membership you get
extra videos and so many great things
and it just feels good it feels good to
be part of a community members
email me daily to tell me how good it
feels to be members
and i will thank everybody who signs up
so for example
pay for subscribers has just signed up
that's not help making me look too good
and his new member number 10 and
um you know that's something we're going
to have to deal with
but in all seriousness uh everything we
do the broadcast show the podcast
studio equipment connectivity the
streams
employee health insurance all of this
stuff our primary funding sources people
who just say hey you know what a dollar
83 a month sounds reasonable i'll grab a
membership at jointpakman.com
so consider yourselves invited consider
yourselves invited
um nicholas de pasquale has grabbed a
soy boy level membership whoa where'd
that go we just
lost a bunch of people yair says
trump said he alone would fix everything
include the united states to his long
list of failed ventures
bank trumpsy yes
has subscribed zesty african says from
the standpoint of doing the most testing
who is more capable at comprehending
high level ideas dave rubin or gore
vidal
i don't want to offend anybody so i'm
going to opt out of commenting on that
stuart keating says beep boop beep
commencing
pacman's subscription david aubin has
signed up
ma magni magne
says cdc recommends travelers avoid all
non-essential international travel
to norway just read this headline news
in norway would you comment maybe later
here is donald trump
it's about to get oh they're not even
live on the white house feed all right
let's see what's going on
oh and they're already using copywritten
music so we're going to wait on that
um why is the white house feed so
delayed like trump's live already
and oh boy dragging that right foot this
is gonna be
wild i can already tell this is gonna be
completely unhinged
he's this is like a rally for trump he's
treating it like a rally i didn't
realize it was gonna be rally mode
fist pump let's see if the music's still
going
it's a great honor to be here and thank
you dan
i'm thrilled to be in the great state of
ohio by the way the governor of ohio
tested positive for covet today and so
that's why he's not here we've been good
to each other
with the incredible men and women of
whirlpool the largest washing machine
factory
anywhere in the world trump's skin tone
is almost identical to the cardboard
behind him
new machines coming rolling off that
beautiful assembly line i just got to
see it
and every single one is proudly
inscribed with that glorious phrase
made in the usa remember made in the usa
when i was campaigning i said let's go
made in the usa put it on your machines
put it on everything we make
i'm grateful to everyone at whirlpool
for welcoming us today including
mark bitzer thank you jim kepler and
sarah bovem thank you very much sarah
where's sarah
thank you thank you very much sarah
beaufort
also with us today as secretary of labor
gene scalia
and a uh he was almost like satisfied
that he got through those three names in
a
not completely embarrassing way champion
and a great guy
jim jordan jim he is
a warrior
jim it's rally time he's tough i'm not
gonna
wrestle him ever i promise
and another warrior great fellow who has
been uh
right at our side he works with jim and
i so much and so
hard bob ladder bob thank you very much
thank you bob also lieutenant governor
john husted
thank you john now why is he there
instead of mike dewine
oh mike dewine has covey state
senate president larry oppoff
larry thank you very much thank you
larry
thank you larry clyde mayor scott black
and many
other distinguished guests great people
great representatives thank you fellas
thank you very much
as we celebrate whirlpool's 109-year
legacy of american manufacturing
excellence today i want to
lay out my vision to bring millions and
millions more jobs
and thousands more factories back to
american chores where they belong we've
been doing it
long and hard one of the longest
successful today
happens to be a meeting i had probably
four years ago with
a very good representative of your
company saying what they were doing to
you and how badly you were being treated
by
other countries and you know what i did
and here we are today the most
successful plant
and we've done this in a lot of places
the duty of a president is to put this
nation's own
citizens first that's why my
administration
swears by two simple but crucial rules
by american and
higher american
and no one knows better than the workers
of whirlpool
the high cost of past administration's
economic blunders and surrender
on the question of foreign trade
previous leaders were guided by a
shameful policy of capitulation
submission and retreat for decades you
watched as politicians let foreign
nations steal our jobs
loot our factories and plunder the crown
jewels of the u.s
economy and the word plunder is
capitalized
washington stood idly by as other
countries engaged in unfair trade
practices
such as massive subsidies currency
manipulation and
in the case of your industry and your
company the wholesale dumping of foreign
made products sold below
cost for the sole purpose of driving you
out of business
so they could give us product at double
triple and quadruple
the price but we didn't let that happen
did we
no one knows what he's talking about
for eight years whirlpool begged the
obama biden administration who did
nothing to protect
american workers from the flagrant
dumping
of foreign washers dryers into america
but your cries for help fell on deaf
ears you didn't
see any action they didn't act they
didn't care
and they never will for eight long years
under
obama biden administration american
factory workers received
nothing but broken promises and brazen
sellouts and lost jobs the last
administration
tied america up in one globalist
debacle after another they catered
to the special interest while allowing
foreign nations to siphon off our wealth
our dignity our dreams our money
the suffering of our workers was met
with nothing but cruel betrayal and
callous
indifference in 2013 the u.s
international trade commission found
your competitors from korea
and other countries guilty this is
literally meaningless drivel
market and ordered them to pay
anti-dumping duties
as high as 79 percent but rather than
whoever wrote this speech is not really
carefully considering the vocabulary i
think
samsung relocated production to another
country a country called
china have you ever heard of it and the
last
administration did nothing as they kept
on dumping washers into the u.s market
with impunity the obama
biden administration was left at they
were
taking a powerful and divine defiant
stance
on uh the gentle cycle that some of
these devices come loaded with
close and you know what it was like i
came through today and everybody was out
there
tremendous crowds waving and cheering
i said i must have done it right because
you had people that were really
really something
because four or five years ago this
place was a disaster
in 2017 whirlpool won relief from the
itc once again
once more your foreign competitors moved
their factories to prevent
a level playing field and to avoid
liability
shifting production to thailand and to
vietnam thailand and vietnam
to places that i like their leaders very
much
they're very nice to us do they take
advantage of the united states
but not so much anymore but this time
there was one big difference
instead of an administration that sold
out american workers and sold your
company out
and couldn't have cared less for you you
finally had a president
who stood up for the american worker on
january 23
2018 at my desk in the oval office i
proudly signed the order to impose a 50
percent tariff on all
foreign-made washing machines
as a result whirlpool's nine factories
across the united states were soon
thriving like never before
investing in new products new
infrastructure and hundreds of new
american jobs and i just took a tour
and i actually wanted a couple of those
machines for myself
yeah but i just didn't know it was going
to be appropriate to ask
i'm sure trump's done laundry before
beautiful that includes thousands of new
jobs across the ohio supply chain
from right here in clyde to findlay
ottawa greenville and marion
[Music]
all over
your company became a shining example
from really a company that was down and
out it became a shining example of
what tough trade policies and smart
tariffs can bring
to jobs and prosperity to communities
like this one all over
ohio michigan wisconsin pennsylvania
and plenty of other states they're all
doing well they were doing great
and the plague came in and now they're
doing great again we closed it up we
saved millions of lives but now
we're opening and it looks like i was
right about the v because you're seeing
the kind of numbers that are coming in
and they're coming in strong they're
coming in stores should have never
happened
should have never happened china should
have never let it happen
in defending your jobs here at whirlpool
i was doing exactly what i promised in
june 2016.
as a candidate for president i stood
before an audience of hard-working
patriots
at a metals processing facility outside
of pittsburgh pennsylvania
they processed quality i plan for a new
america first trade policy
and it was even a better job
than i told you i'm one politician that
says i'm gonna do this and then we do
better
we produced more than i promised and by
the way the wall is being built it's
gonna be finished very soon
who even believes that at this point our
politicians have aggressively pursued a
policy of globalization
moving our jobs our wealth and our
factories overseas
i explained that globalization these are
the globalists
i'm not liking globalists too much they
don't like me too much either
globalization has made the financial
elites
who donate to politicians very wealthy
but it's left millions and millions of
our workers
with nothing but poverty and heartache
in our towns and cities with empty
factories and plants
for years later we've made extraordinary
progress in reversing the dangerous tide
of globalism
over a period of four to five years this
took place think of it fourteen doesn't
know what he's talking about yeah what
we've done
is a miracle and now it's getting
even better because we've taken
additional steps
and you know when you do these steps you
have to go through statutory procedures
it's not like
boom i'm going to just sign it has to go
out for 90 days of review
then 120 days of review then more and we
did it as quick as we can
we're doing it right now with the fda
we're getting vaccines approved in days
that nobody thought possible
it would take years and years and we're
doing it in months
we're doing very well under my
administration we're fighting for main
street not
wall street we rejected globalism and
embraced
patriotism in my speech in pittsburgh
in june of 2016 i made seven big
promises
to american workers many politicians
before me promised change on the
campaign trail
only to back down in the face of
corporate and international
pressure like jerusalem they all
promised
crucial didn't they jerusalem years and
years
i did it they didn't do it they didn't
do it i did it
move the embassy to jerusalem
making jerusalem the capital of israel
they all talked about it he really
doesn't understand anything does he
and then they got into office and they
didn't do it he has no idea what he's
talking about the pressure was enormous
on me too
i just didn't take the phone calls
that's true leaders would call up from
other countries
i'd say i know what they're calling
about i'll call them back in a few days
then i just signed all the papers got it
done and then i called them back
they said i was calling about israel in
jerusalem
but you've already done it i said that's
right imagine being a factory worker who
makes washing machines and trump shows
up and talks about this
got me a little bit earlier how does
this impact your day-to-day economic
circumstances
kept every single one first i promised
to withdraw the united states from
the last administration's disastrous
assault
on u.s workers the trans
pacific partnership would have been a
disaster
would have been a disaster especially
for the automobile industry would have
put it out of business
my first week in office i kept that
promise and canceled that
job-killing catastrophe
second i pledge to appoint the toughest
and smartest trade
negotiators to defend american jobs and
i did with bob lighthizer
has the crowd left third i said i would
use every legal tool at my disposal
to fight back against unfair trade and i
did and i found some that nobody even
knew about
some of them were very old they had a
lot of dust on them hadn't been used for
decades and decades
but i found them things you could never
get past today
fourth i promised to label china
a currency manipulator and i did
fifth i said we would bring trade cases
against china to crack down on its
economic aggression
sixth i committed to impose tariffs on
goods to protect american jobs and stop
china and many other countries abuses
under section 232 of the trade expansion
act
of 1962 and section 301
of the trade act of 1974.
as your president i have kept every
single one of these pledges to the
american people
and to the american worker without
exception everyone has been done
seventh one of my biggest promises in
that speech was to replace the disaster
known as nafta one of the worst trade
deals
ever made by any country let alone ours
ohio lost almost 40
of its manufacturing jobs after nafta
was signed
half of all of the automaking jobs
across the state
this is actually a great example you
know recently i've been talking about
how populist rhetoric can really trick
people
and trump is now going back into the
populist rhetoric of his 2015-2016
campaign which as we know
populist rhetoric can lead to extremely
authoritarian policy
it's very easy to be tricked by the
language of populism and that's exactly
what trump is going back to here
that was the biggest point i made i want
to make sure that
these companies aren't leaving and the
managers walk
up and they say i'm sorry our company's
leaving going to mexico
or canada but going primarily in that
case
to mexico canada takes advantage of us
with dairy
unbelievable advantage but not anymore
but mexico took a lot of jobs and i said
i don't want
companies moving and if they do move
remember you've heard it
if they do move when they make that
product they got to pay a big price to
sell it back into our country
so they have no more incentive to move
the us mca contains powerful new
protections for american manufacturers
automakers farmers dairy producers
and workers all across ohio
and all of our states those were key
promises i made to american workers in
2016. i kept every single
one of them the fake news media back
there they hate to report this
they hate it
[Music]
here we go why do they hate it because
they're fake
today to define our path forward i'm
making our incredible workers six more
promises that i will keep
over the next four years and i'm very
proud to make them
at your plant and in the state of ohio
take note
first and foremost we will defeat the
china virus we're working very very hard
we call it we will it has nothing to do
with trump that we will eventually
defeat it call it many different names
got many different names
but it's bad and we've made tremendous
strides we're attacking the virus from
every angle and through
this aggressive strategy we will win the
war
and it will happen sooner than people
think we're developing
a bounty of therapies such as
remdisserver
rim disavow say body treatments the
antibody treatments are really working
out well say it
really well and many more that have
allowed us to reduce mortality by
85 since april no plasma under operation
warp speed two
vaccines are already in the final stage
of clinical trials
and we'll have a vaccine very soon i
hope long before the end of the year
we've dramatically increased our
domestic production of personal
protective equipment domestic such as
n95 respirators gowns and gloves
we've got factories now all over the
united states making these products
and we've developed the most advanced
testing system on earth to produce our
most and and this is what we have to do
not only cleanliness and perfection in
every way but we have to protect our
most
vulnerable citizens against this
horrible
virus and that's generally speaking the
elderly especially the elderly with
problems of the heart problems with the
heart
and diabetes in particular those two are
a basic disaster our strategy
shelters those at highest risk while
allowing those at lower risk to get
safely back to work and to school
instead of a never-ending blanket locked
down causing severe long-term
we never had that now the health
consequences we've targeted and
looked at data-driven approaches and
that's what we're doing
again when you close down and we had to
do it initially because it came and hit
us
big hard and nobody knew what it was and
we saved millions of lives
but today you just pinpointed we know
what to do and we know who to protect as
an example very young children
are incredibly powerful they're much
stronger than all of us
when it comes to the immune system it's
an incredible thing to see
just about everything he's saying is not
true and we know what to do
and let me tell you lockdowns have big
consequences
in terms of drugs in terms of family in
terms of depression
and suicide in terms of so many other
problems that are caused
and not good for the kids and they don't
learn the same at a computer as they do
when they're in a classroom
computer so there are big big problems
with lockdown
but we cannot defeat the virus by
fighting against each other
just can't and uh there are a lot of
different theories in a lot of different
ways but if you look at some of the
results
you'll see some of the states governor
run
some of the states that are open and run
very smart are doing
very well and in fact better than strong
lockdown states
now is the time to come together as
americans and to unite against the
plague
inflicted upon us by china together we
will prevail my second promise
to you is this oh my god that was all
only one adversity
of this horrible invisible enemy
and we will be more prosperous and
resilient than ever before we've done
things that we never knew we could do
we're building factories now we're
building plants
you'll see what's going to be happening
with the job numbers very soon
we had two of the best months ever in
the history of our country
and we're going to have many many very
very
successful years many many very very
destroys it by doubling tripling and
quadrupling your taxes and
quadrupling something else called
regulations yep
biden will quadru if you're very wealthy
instead of paying 35 percent you'll pay
140
if you make 100 grand you'll owe someone
140
grand it's going to be crazy to adapt
and repurpose its factories
today using the defense production act
which we've used often
remember they'd always say oh use the
defense production act
we've used it a lot more than some
companies would like to know
we're engaged in the most rapid
industrial mobilization
by far since world war ii over the last
six months we've witnessed one
manufacturing miracle after another
we've seen general motors repurpose an
auto parts facility
in kokomo indiana
great state and thereby stand up it
seemed to pain him to say kokomo their
factory
literally in a matter of days and we're
now producing
thousands and thousands of ventilators a
week
general motors has now built and
delivered more than
20 000 ventilators by next week our
strategic national stockpile will be
equipped to deploy more than 100 000
ventilators
they're very expensive to build they're
very complex
very very complex machines and
the big and i said that we are now
supplying ventilators
to many countries of the world everybody
in our country has it
not one person and we had no ventilators
who knew about ventilators we had very
few
but not one person who needed we had 19
000 in the stockpile needed a ventilator
didn't get it
every person that needed a ventilator
got it who would have thought that was
possible and you remember at the very
beginning when you first heard about
this whole horrible situation with the
gina virus
ventilators they weren't around and now
we have 19 thousands of thousands
working with gm and almost a dozen other
companies great companies my
administration has turned america
into the ventilator king of the world
the
ventilator king make them good and we
make them great
like the used car king quality we're now
exporting ventilators to
friends and allies and they're really
thankful they're calling
can i have ventilators for our country
sir
how many do you need could you send a
thousand honestly at this point what
country needs more ventilators than us
other than brazil china and russia i
mean we're
we need the most ventilators really
things you can make
gowns and swabs and things you can make
we're making them too
but ventilators are tough ventilators
are just one part of our historic
manufacturing ramp up
within seven days of new york city
officials asking for assistance last
spring
we helped ship a million yards of fabric
from north carolina to new york city
for masks and gowns we're making them
all over the place
a great company honeywell has opened up
n95 respirator factories in rhode island
and arizona in record time
and they're now churning out tens of
millions of people for our strategic
national stockpile these include
manufacturing achievements
and these are incredible they'll be the
foundation
of an even brighter future for american
industry what we've been able to do in a
short period of time is frankly
incredible i'm not talking about me i'm
talking about the people out there what
they've done
is incredible including the military and
some of the generals and admirals i
think we're still on the second of six
new promises guys
build on these gains to turn america
into the premier
medical manufacturer pharmacy and
drugstore of the world
okay as we've seen in this pandemic the
united states must produce
essential equipment supplies and
pharmaceuticals for ourselves
we cannot rely on china and other
nations across the globe
that could one day deny us products in a
time of need we can't do it we can't do
it
we have to be smart and speaking of
pharmaceuticals we instituted four
moves rebates favored nations
coupons and other things buying from
other nations
where they have the product the same
exact pill identical made in the same
factory
for a fraction just a small fraction of
the cost we buy from other countries as
opposed to buying through this
ridiculous quagmire political
scam every once in a while i remember
this is the president of the united
states
what i've done in terms of favorite
nations if as an example
germany has a pill for 10 cents and we
have a bill for two dollars
we institute favorite nations of the
drug company we get the pill
i like this action we have a pill we
have a pill
anywhere in the world
and that could drop your price of
pharmaceuticals of
drugs prescription drugs could drop your
price
50 60 70 maybe more than that this is
something
now i have to tell you i have never seen
so many bad commercials about me as in
the last three days since i did this
so will you remember that when you see
this horrible
commercial that i'm a socialist i was
called a socialist for the first time in
my entire life
actually what i am doing is i'm using
socialist countries who are buying our
product for
far less than we're allowed to i'm
saying well if you're going to sell it
to this country
it might be socialist for a lower price
so we're going to get that same price so
you know
what but i have been called everything
in the book and i say i said the other
day
whenever you see a drug company
advertising that donald trump's a bad
guy remember your drug prices
must be coming down very big remember he
admitted
it probably would be six months before
the stuff he did will bring prices down
please remember that because i don't
want to get all those negative votes and
then
biden wins and they try the first month
he'll say i dropped drug prices
78 percent and he won't even know what
the hell he's saying
here we go i don't want to be watching
that from some beautiful resort
someplace in the world i could have oh i
had such a beautiful life before i did
this but that's okay
because we're doing a great job why did
we make him be president guys he didn't
even want it
being properly representative
represented for a change
but during the course of the next four
years we will bring our
pharmaceutical and medical supply chains
home we're gonna bring them home where
they belong and that's
c-h-a-m-e-s just like we did with the
washers and dryers just like we did
with many other things we'll be making
our product here
safely beautifully and inexpensive we're
still on policy number two we're
reasserting
american economic independence and i've
been doing that from the first day i
came into office to this end a short
time ago i signed the new executive
order to ensure that when it comes to
essential medicines we buy
american
the executive order will require that
you ask so just so everybody knows on
trump's schedule this was scheduled
to be 55 minutes start to finish which
would have been 3
15 to 4 10. i don't actually remember
when it started but it looks like it's
on track to go very long if we're still
on promise number two of six
and support advanced manufacturing
processes that will keep our drug prices
low
and allow american companies to compete
on the world stage
we'll be able to compete on the world
stage but we're now going to have the
lowest prices
as opposed to by far the highest prices
i have people that i know that go to
canada
is this even relatable like to the
average voter who has the
as we've heard you know economic
insecurity does anybody even know what
the hell he's talking about does like
does this allay anyone's anxieties
economically to hear him rant about this
stuff incoherently
it's a disgrace and the politicians
allowed this to happen for
many many decades you have people called
middlemen i don't know who the middlemen
are
i don't know if they never say middle
women so they're politically not correct
but i've heard the term middlemen for a
long time they are so wealthy
they are so wealthy nobody has any idea
who the hell they are what they do they
make more money than the drug companies
you know in all fairness when they make
money it's bad when trump makes money
it's good
it has to be a good product but the
middlemen
well the rebate that i'm doing cuts out
the middleman and it reduces costs and
the
money goes back to the people purchasing
the drugs
someone just just to turn up turn up the
walk-off music and and play them off
they're very very rich enemies but they
are not happy with what i'm doing
but i figure we have one chance to do it
and no other president is going to do
what i do
no other president will know a favored
nations
a rebate a buy from other nations at
much less cost nobody
and there are a lot of unhappy people
and they're very rich people
and they're very unhappy here's my
fourth promise to american workers did
we skip number three
medical supply chains over the next four
years
we will launch your millions of new
manufacturing jobs across many other
critical sectors that are
vital to our national security and
prosperity
from electronics to machines skip all of
them for all i care space autos
and of course to iron and to steal
and we'll never forget your washers and
your dryers
okay during eight years of the last
administration
and by the way i have to just tell you
this little story a couple of little
stories
oh no do you mind okay cause that's
better than the other stuff right
no i was with somebody and they said you
know for a dishwasher
we don't have enough water sir oh no a
lot of the people in the audience would
understand what i'm saying oh no he's
going into the indoor plumbing ranch
stricter zone so you don't have any
water and
i said what is that what is that in most
states i mean outside of desert areas we
have so much water we don't know what to
do with it right a lot of states your
state does pretty well
i hope he talks about flushing a toilet
15 times
so i passed a regulation i signed a
regulation that give the dishwashers
much more water and i was asking today
and that by the way includes your
washers
you don't need too much water in your
dryers but it includes your washers
and i was just saying to your brilliant
people that are
doing such a good job running your
company i said how much impact has that
had
they said unbelievable it's been
unbelievable because i had people saying
they'd wash their dishes and they'd
press the button five times
so in the end they're probably wasting
more water than they did he doesn't know
how a dishwasher works
the people that make the machines you
know what i'm talking about we now have
the water that you need instead of
stupid where you have much less water
than you need and you just keep going
over and over again i had people say
that press the button five times
they didn't have enough water press the
button and the same thing with
sinks toilets and showers here we go
please do choice i went to a new home
please do turn on the faucet no water
comes out you turn on the shower
if you're like me you can't wash your
beautiful hair properly
please do toilet paper 20 minutes longer
please come out the water it drips right
you know what i'm talking they put
restrictors on
i got rid of that i signed it out that's
common sense
so now when you actually go into a new
home and pay a lot of money you turn on
a faucet and water actually comes out
isn't that nice
that was a regulation trump wants you to
believe that when you go to places that
have indoor plumbing and water comes out
it's thanks to him
using the same amount of water you just
let it run three times longer
it's crazy and one other thing i did
remember the old light bulb
the old light bulb was so great and they
put it out of business
it was much cheaper and it had much
better light
and you're all good-looking people but
you look better under the old light bulb
than that horrible
no light bulb right of course your
fraction of the cost didn't last as long
but that's okay but it cost you a
fraction
i reinstituted and opened it up so they
can sell both they can sell the new one
what a victory trump has
pushed bad light bulbs again amazing
business
amazing business and you know the new
one i think this guy discovered fire and
probably invented the wheel
lose it you're supposed to take it down
to a a dump
a specified dump how many people are
going to do that with a light bulb hey
you know we lost this light bulb let's
travel 28 miles outside of the city to
get rid of it
it's hazardous waste so i put the old
bulb back in and you can use the new one
you can use anything
i guess it's competition but i
particularly like it because i don't
look so
orange so it's very nice oh my god
very nice
i don't want to look i don't like that
look never liked it
but it's a tremendous thing and it's
having tremendous success so
they'll you know scoff and say oh who
cares about that very big stuff you know
these are big things a lot of people
have come up thank you sir
they had sinks that didn't give water
they had showers that didn't give water
the whole thing and
and uh it's been a great thing it's been
very popular
and we might as well tell you about it
because people don't talk about it but
these are things that no other president
would be doing no other president
frankly would be even thinking about i
agree no other president would be
bragging about
inventing indoor plumbing that's true 10
000 factories and nearly 200 000
manufacturing jobs think of that
in contrast my administration added over
a half a million manufacturing jobs it
was up to actually 701 thousand
jobs before the plague came in and
if you remember president obama
you need a magic wand no you don't we
need manufacturing jobs he said you
won't have any more manufacturing jobs
you need a magic wand he was wrong about
that also
what my fifth promise to american
workers is to bring back american jobs
and factories using every tool
at my disposal including tariffs i love
properly
put on tariffs remember american
businesses pay the tariffs
competitors from foreign countries to do
whatever you want them to do
countervailing duties and new trade
deals based on the principle of fairness
and reciprocity
and i'll be signing something very
important watch over the next week i
think you'll be very proud of your
president i'm going to be signing
something that's very
important over the next probably
and it'll have a tremendous impact on
fairness and trade as part of this
commitment
earlier today i signed a proclamation
that defends american industry by
reimposing
aluminum tariffs on canada canada was
taking advantage of us
as usual yeah good i like that the only
thing i'd be
impressed with is him signing his
resignation by
canada very unfair to our jobs and our
great
aluminum workers several months ago
my administration agreed to lift those
tariffs in return for a promise
from the canadian government that its
aluminum industry would not flood our
country with exports
and kill all our aluminum jobs which is
exactly what they did
canadian aluminum producers have broken
that commitment and the us trade
representative robert lighthizer
has advised me that this step to
reimpose tariffs is absolutely necessary
to defend our aluminum industry
to be a strong nation america must be a
manufacturing nation
and not be led by a bunch of fools
that means protecting our national
industrial base we have to protect
our great companies and our great
workers
my sixth and final promise today is to
forever uphold the commitment i made
from the beginning
i will always put american workers first
always they'll always be prepared
okay cool six promises
and i don't know if you're union or
non-union it doesn't matter to me
but i did one hell of a good job for the
unions you know all the union heads are
against me but all the workers are for
me so something's right
that's not true for me the union heads
their wined and dined in washington
pretty good by the democrats
as part of this commitment on monday i
signed an executive order to prevent
government agencies like the tennessee
valley authority
from replacing american workers with
cheap foreign labor
there's a very big utility run by a man
that gets
eight million dollars a year would
anybody in this room like that job eight
million
eight million a year right highest paid
he's really doesn't work for me i
wouldn't pay 8 million if you pay them
the president gets 400 450 000
i give up my salary nobody ever says
super relatable here i'll say it
i believe i'm the only president to do
that and i'm saying
that's not too smart but the tennessee
valley
authority pays eight million dollars a
year to the head
and after the authority laid off 20
of its american technology workforce and
forced them to train their foreign
replacements this week
i told the chairman of the board you're
fired
and the firings will continue unless the
layoffs are reversed and the american
workers are rehired
and by the way as i was leaving for the
great state
of ohio did you ever watch biden where
he's always saying the wrong state it's
great to be in
florida florida no it's ohio
i've never seen a guy haven't done that
one yet that's a disaster
i always say jim jordan if you do that
it's over
right you can be winston churchill the
speech is over just walk off the stage
but he does it all the time nobody calls
him for i love the state
of iowa sir sir it's idaho
it's idaho and the worst is what he's in
like indiana
and he says it's great to be with the
people of florida and you have palm
trees all over the place
but he does it all the time what there's
something going on
but over the last four years we've made
extraordinary strides and over the next
four years together we will turn the
united states
into the unrivaled manufacturing
superpower of the world we've been
through
a lot together
they've done everything possible to get
in my way they've treated us very
unfairly
disgracefully with what they've done to
us
and despite what they've done no
administration in the history of this
country has done more in the first three
and a half years than we have
whether it's rebuilding our military
obviously
meaningless life whether it's the
biggest tax cuts in history
whether it's uh the biggest regulation
cuts in history
and war in alaska the largest field
perhaps in the world that
uh ronald reagan uh going back even
before ronald reagan no president could
get it approved i got it approved and
now it's
potentially one of the greatest sites in
the world should be the greatest site in
the world so many different things we've
done we've done so much
what we've done for our vets and you're
a big vet state
ohio loves its vets and what we've done
for our vets
choice and accountability we got two
things they've been trying for almost 50
years
choice veterans choice veterans choice
was a 2014
obama era policy which trump has tried
to appropriate
he had to wait two months sometimes if
they had to wait online
they don't anymore they go outside they
get a private doctor we approve it we
pay the bill
obama we take care of our vets like
they're supposed to be 2014.
just got a 91 approval ready
va just got a 91 approval rating highest
ever the highest it's ever had and
accountability we have people that are
so
we're so scornful and hatred for our
vets they were treating our vets badly
our vets have to be treated great
but you couldn't fire them they could be
sadistic they could be thieves they
could be
you couldn't fire because of civil
service unions etc you know
couldn't fire them and i got the
accountability va accountability now you
look at them they don't do a good job
for our vets you say jim you're fired
boom get out absolutely we actually
terminated over 8 000 people that were
trump the economic populist bragging
about making it easier to fire people
a bit cold but the truth is they got to
treat our vets well right so they have
to do it
but we got accountability and we got va
choice but to achieve
the vision that we've been
talking about for so long we must finish
the job
and drain the washington swamp once and
for all
and we're doing it
for years left-wing politicians smiled
and looked
at american workers right in the eye and
took advantage of them and lied to them
they took
your endorsements they took your money
and they took your votes and they did
nothing
then they turned around and inflicted
one corrupt betrayal of the american
middle class
after another whether it's a word salad
but a bad one like with that rancid
romaine that was going around for a
while ridiculous paris
climate accord how's it working out for
paris not so good and
china's entry into the world trade
organization which is probably the worst
of all the deals if you want to know the
truth
that was where china signed that and
they went up like a rocket ship
and they violated the rules like
nobody's ever violated him before
in fact they're considered a developing
nation and because they're a developing
nation they have advantages
well we didn't accept that but for years
they accepted that
and by the way joe biden supported every
single one of those horrible disastrous
sellouts
it's free word association
administration those days have been over
and we're not going back we're respected
again as a country you know we're
respected again
no you may not feel it although i think
you do no we don't feel
you don't read about it from the fake
news but this country's respected again
we don't let people take advantage of us
including our allies who took tremendous
advantage of us
tremendous
our allies took tremendous advantage of
us both militarily where they don't pay
their bills
we protect them they don't pay like
germany we're reducing the force they
don't pay they delinquent i say it all
the time they delinquent they got to pay
you know we protect germany from russia
and yet
germany's paying billions of dollars
a year billions and billions to russia
for energy
so i say what's that all about so we
protect and they pay money
and we protect so uh
we don't stand for things like that but
we have many other things i could stand
up here all day long until we do things
that you wouldn't
we must stop the radical left-wing
movement that would destroy our country
they want to impose three trillion
dollars of new taxes on american
families
they want to ban fracking which will
demolish
your state it will demolish ohio
oil and gas jobs they want to rejoin the
disastrous paris climate accord
where you'll pay billions and billions
of dollars
for the privilege of getting ripped off
by other countries
and inflict a socialist takeover of the
u.s economy
right known as the horrendous green new
deal was conceived by
it's really the u.s could be socialist
before you know it that's a real risk
three i say aoc that's a real beauty
isn't it
she knows as much about the environment
do we have any young children here
as that young child over there i think
he knows more
and she certainly knows nothing about
the economy and if they ever had their
chance you would find that out and it
wouldn't take very long you know
venezuela was a very wealthy country 20
years ago one of the wealthiest
per capita one of the wealthiest
tremendous oil reserves everything
now he claims to understand per capita
they don't have medicine they don't have
anything
same thing could happen same or similar
ideology
they also want to throw open american
borders
give free taxpayer-funded health care to
illegal aliens
defund police abolish ice
abolish borders no more borders and
abolish basically the american dream
this is joe biden and does anybody
really think he's strong enough
to stand up to these ruthless vicious
people you look at
you look at portland you look at what's
going on in seattle
these are the people that you're dealing
with if i didn't send in the troops if i
didn't send in the great people from
homeland security you'd have courthouses
and post offices and everything else
burned down no no no he's trying to
destroy the post offices not the
protesters
been riding now for 70 days and the
mayor thinks it's just wonderful and the
governor has no idea what she's doing
i've never seen people like this
remember in seattle
where they took over a big chunk of the
city seattle
and the mayor said
it's going to be a summer of love
and i said she's just kidding right
isn't she she wasn't kidding
but we were all set to send in the
troops send in the
people that we were going to send in and
what happened is amazing we told them
and all of a sudden the police went out
and they cleaned it up
but that place would still be occupied
if we didn't get involved same thing
with minneapolis
minneapolis it was a disaster after five
or six days they were gonna lose that
whole city
we sent in the national guard they took
care of things in about one hour
remember the scene of them walking down
the street
firing the tear gas now you're not even
allowed if you're looking at the other
side you're not allowed to use tear gas
trump loves tear gas pepper spray can't
use any of that stuff
they can use molotov cocktails
and horrible things on you but you're
not allowed to do anything so
the police didn't want to have anything
to do with the convention in a great
state
wisconsin milwaukee for the democrats
you couldn't use tear gas you couldn't
use pepper spray you couldn't use
anything think of how ridiculous this
is and you won't be able to use your
guns because they're going to end your
second amendment as sure as you're
sitting there
but the proud people of ohio will not
let that happen
together we will preserve protect and
defend
our american way of life as long as i am
president
thank you okay meaningless rival today
thank you particularly as long as i am
president of the united states i will
fight
for you with every ounce of energy and
strength that i have
i will be your voice i will defend your
jobs
i will stand up to the foreign trade
cheaters and violators that hate our
country
i will never let you down i will have
your back one hundred percent
for more than a century the workers of
this company
have continued the proud tradition of
american greatness
embodied by your legendary founder lou
upton
it's a heritage grounded in the values
of hard work and determination
innovation and excellence faith and
family
loyalty and patriotism passed down from
one generation to the next you have an
incredible heritage
these are the values that have defined
this company
and defined our country from the very
beginning
and they are the values that will define
our future
that will ensure our success and that
will allow
america to thrive and win for many
generations to come
there is nobody that can defeat us
nobody
now i'd like to take just a moment to
a few of the whirlpool men and women's
jobs i had the honor of
taking decisive action to protect and to
save
kerry wallace is an operations analyst
whose family has 100 years of history at
this very plant
kerry please come forward and say a few
words please
this is outrageous
you gary
good afternoon manufacturing is the
heartbeat of this area
ripple has an enormous impact
on the state of ohio economically
my family has proudly worked in these
walls for four generations
like mr president said for combined
over a hundred years
i had the opportunity to get some advice
from my mother
advice that was passed down from my
grandfather which i was actually just
able to pass down to my nephew
there is not another company that would
provide financial security
and career opportunities in this area
like whirlpool
it's true the opportunities here are
endless for us
whirlpool has rewarded me with a
completely new family also
i work with 3 500 proud individuals
together we build american made quality
products here in clyde
we bleed whirlpool blue i'm grateful for
the support that we received in 2018
from the president that support gives us
the ability to compete and deliver
in the market place now and for many
generations to come
thank you karen wow
great job
marco antavares is a first generation
american who
started at this plant to support his
family 17 years ago
marco rose through leadership to become
a production lead
marco please come up and say a few words
please
thank you mr president
as the president said i started here
about 16 going on 17 years
i was fresh out of high school had no
idea what i wanted to do with my life
but i knew i had two young children that
i had to support and i had to support
fast
i'm honored to say that i found that
here at whirlpool
within these four walls i have been able
to not only provide but continue to
develop myself into a career path that i
never would have dreamed of when i was
18 years old coming out of there
as miss wallace stated i too am very
grateful for the tariffs that were put
against our foreign competitors in 2018
to take that instability away from our
everyday lives
and provide a longevity of stability
and support for these american jobs here
in these four laws
as our president said i am a first
generation
from an immigrant family my father was
an immigrant he came here to chase the
american dream and i could say
i'm fortunate enough to find my american
dream within these four laws here at
whirlpool
thank you very much
[Applause]
okay thank you both and you know marco
had a beautiful
speech written and he never looked down
you never even looked down at that
speech
i'm impressed with both of you i'm
impressed to every worker here at
whirlpool thank you once again for
welcoming us
it's an honor to be here and thank you
for your commitment to
american manufacturing you're a great
company with great great people
together we will bring back our jobs we
will bring back our factories and we
will bring back
our american dream god bless you and god
bless america thank you very much
thank you thank you um
okay i mean it's hard to feel too
inspired by what we're seeing here
[Music]
just kind of are they doing ymca again i
don't want to get hit with copyright so
i'm going to bring it down
ah what it what just what can you do
with psy right what a bizarre event if
you are heading out
um if you're watching on youtube please
remember to hit that subscribe button it
really helps me out
we're trying to get to a million
subscribers by election day it costs
nothing and you'll be notified of future
streams so please do hit that subscribe
button
don't think i'm ignoring you if you're
watching on twitch i would love it if
you also followed there is a very very
sweaty donald trump
waving a final goodbye there joe biden
is speaking i do want to come over and
just take a very brief look
um at what is going on with joe biden so
we're monitoring this here
and we will keep an eye on it
but what a very strange strange
event for donald trump and i think these
events are sort of serving as proxies to
the rallies that donald trump would like
to be having
um but really can't responsibly have
right i mean it seems that that's
he's just desperate desperate desperate
um
from uh for those rallies and unable to
have them now i actually i'm unsure
is joe biden still speaking here let's
see if he wrapped up this was just a few
seconds ago
let's take a listen and embrace the
largest population
of immigrants in the world in the united
states and include them across the board
it's a source of amazing strength for us
as i said i think because of this
coveted crisis and unemployment crisis
i think the american people are seeing
that now
at least i hope that's the case i'm
going to need your help if i'm elected
to get all this done
may god bless you all may god protect
our troops
thank you
thank you mr vice president for your
remarks okay so it actually seems like
it may have been pre-taped
um thank you pedro and edison
international for all you do in support
of our or
okay it's over i guess that was just a
brief uh pre-taped message
all right well listen thank you
everybody for uh joining me i very much
appreciate it
uh please remember we are right now in a
very intense and
kind of ugly battle with sam cedar in a
race to a million subscribers who's
gonna get there first
so please do remember hit that subscribe
button
uh we are currently at 923
000. we could be at 9 33 instantly if
everybody hit that button i'll be back
very soon with much more
um and uh keep the memes coming to david
davidpakman.com
you